thank you
excuse me
foreign
yoga
District
eventually
[Music]
foreign
well thank you very much uh Mr Prime
Minister nearly one year ago uh we made
a commitment to commit not only to build
a better infrastructure but to build a
better future
one rooted an opportunity security and
prosperity for all
and thanks to all the public and private
Partners around this table
many more around the world we've already
begun to deliver
together we've initiated quality and
sustainable infrastructure projects
across Africa Asia and the Americas and
we're strengthening our shared climate
security health security and food
security and economic security all four
are critical we started to engage more
private investors to better de-risk and
leverage additional capital and I see at
least two from the United States here
that are de-risking a lot
and I'm proud to announce that the
United States has already mobilized more
than 30 billion dollars in Investments
to date and we're just getting started
together we have a lot of work to do to
close the infrastructure Gap and for in
low and middle income countries
and as we begin the next year our
partnership we need to find new ways new
ways to maximize Investments our
investments that's why moving forward
the United States will enhance our focus
on investing in key economic corridors
in practice that means making
game-changing investments in regions
that could lead to positive impacts
across multiple sectors in multiple
countries
we've already started working with our
partners to make this happen for example
in sub-Saharan Africa the U.S
development Finance Corporation is
looking to invest in this first Railway
project on the continent
a rail line would extend from the
Western shores of Angola to the border
of the DRC in Zambia but the goal of
ultimately reaching Indian Ocean
connecting the continent east to west
for the first time
this project will not only quickly
promote trade and create jobs over time
in my view it will strengthen Supply
chains incentive and incentivize
investments in agriculture and promote
food security
and it's going to enable in my view us
to better access clean energy and
digital connectivity across the entire
region creating more security more
Prosperity more opportunities for
generations to come
that's what our focus on the key
economic quarters is all about
investing in near-term solutions that
pay long-term dividends it's not only in
Africa starting similar work in Costa
Rica Ecuador Indonesia and other places
I won't bore you with now
let me close to this during the G7
meeting we're addressing a range of
issues climate change
food security gender inequality economic
resilience digital connectivity and
Global Security
we're tracking these challenges together
and I think we're beginning to make some
important progress but if we don't move
to do more to strengthen infrastructure
and Low Middle income countries if we
don't do more to help Nations deliver
opportunities and prosperity for their
people our impact is going to be limited
that's how the crit how critical this
partnership is that's how important our
investments are so today as we begin the
pgii the second year let's all find ways
to maximize our investment maximize it
because it will do a lot not only for
that particular undertaking but it has
an impact across the entire regions in
my view
and uh to unlock even more public and
private capital
and together let's recommit to showing
that democracies can deliver let me say
it again
democracies can deliver we have to
deliver to people around the world I
want to thank you all for your
partnership leadership in this violation
and now I'm going to turn it back to the
Prime Minister thank you
foreign
[Music]
has been described pgii an initiative of
600 billion dollars top quality
infrastructure where Europe is proud to
contribute half of it we want ice level
partnership with the partner countries
we want to find solutions to the real
challenges low and middle income
countries are facing today
and we want to be part of the
investments in infrastructure projects
that bring good jobs and Lasting growth
and very important they create value
locally
now to reach this goal we need the
private sector
so this could take us from the billions
to the trillions we need you and that's
why we're here today I know that you
want to know that we are in this for the
Long Haul yes this is for sure we are in
this for the Long Haul
we want to work with our country partner
countries
asparency strengthen the regulatory
environment and develop skills I know
that such a conducive and Regulatory
clear environment is essential for you
to have the necessary predictability and
security for capital investment
global gateway the European part of this
initiative has started 90 projects
worldwide so far let me share just three
examples in Namibia Namibia we are
providing guarantees for private
investments in green hydrogen
the goal here is twofold ensure clean
energy for the country itself and
generate new revenues for the country in
a way that it is able to export the
green hydrogen for example to the
European Union in Roman Rwanda we are
working with a vaccine producer to bring
the MRNA technology to Rwanda so that in
this country together with you the
private sector the country is able to
produce the life-saving vaccines for the
region in the Philippines we are
connecting our Copernicus satellite to
build the first Earth observation system
in Southeast Asia and Nokia who is with
us today here is investing in 4G and 5G
infrastructure
so here the corporation will support
National and Regional capacities to
tackle the impact of climate change and
improve disaster risk management
so these were a few brief examples for
the incredible power that public-private
partnership can unleash and I'm glad to
announce that we are now mobilizing an
extra 4 billion euros in loans for the
Asian and Pacific regions
ladies and gentlemen
um the G7 partnership is our effort to
be part of the solution to the
infrastructure investment Gap we want to
put a better offer on the table if we
are in a race we are in a race to the
top
and we will continue to work after
Hiroshima in the next with the next
presidencies of G7 in Italy and in 2025
in Canada
so happy to have you on board and I want
to invite you already to the first
global gateway Forum in Brussels in
October this year thank you for joining
us
[Music]
um
good evening everyone I'm honored to be
here at this side event tonight the
Japan foreign Trader council is an
industry organization I'm representing
various types of the trade related
entities
one of which are so-called Sogo shosha
or Diversified trading Conger Merit
we are a group of unique firms involved
in a broad range of businesses worldwide
from Upstream to Downstream in a supply
chains of many different Industries in
infrastructure development the so-called
social organized project in their
entirety not only do we act as investors
we are also involved in initial project
planning the structuring structuring the
overall financing and overseeing the
construction as well as the operation
and maintenance management
we have a long and proven track record
not only in the renewable energy but
also public transportation which helps a
lower carbon emissions
Mission and desalination projects to
tackle water shortages and so many
others we believe the key to the success
of the infrastructure project is the
good coordination and collaboration
among the wide range of stakeholders
from mdbs the private investors the
government literators to local
communities
the way the solo shows shall work
through communication to benefit all the
stakeholders fits well with pgii's
philosophy or promoting quality
infrastructure in vestment through
public private partnership
we are now at the critical juncture in
human history highlighted by the
importance of uploading the principle of
a free and open International order
based upon rule of law
so we welcome pgii as an initiative that
can help to protect and enhance this
principle
and we expect that the governments and
other stakeholders around the table
will work together hand in hand to
further improve the investment
environment and promote public-private
partnership thank you very much
hey Google
[Music]
thank you very much prayer Mr kashida
I'm President Biden and president vonder
Laden and your excellencies um good
afternoon thank you very much for
inviting City to participate today
um we do bring a unique perspective of
doing business in 160 countries around
the world and that includes Decades of
experience working on the ground in many
Emerging Markets supporting investment
and driving economic growth in alignment
with the objectives of pgii
we understand the challenges as well as
the opportunities that come with
addressing the massive infrastructure
needs of the developing world and the
reality is of what it actually takes to
get things done on the ground
with President asrimini here I'm
delighted to highlight our work
financing of 125 million dollar
revolving credit facility to support
female entrepreneurs in the Kenya Gabon
in Nigeria and the DRC our efforts
extend around the world that includes a
450 million dollar sustainability link
bond which is increasing digital access
in Costa Rica and the financing for a
350 million dollar wind farm in
Northeast Brazil
I'm President we do do we're also
helping finance a 400 million dollar
green bond to support geothermal power
in Indonesia
we're proud of this work that we do
around the world but we know that much
more needs to be done and we certainly
welcome the efforts to reform
multilateral development Banks to be
clear however more MDB financing just
use the same way is not going to get us
where we need to be
instead it's about how to use MDB
financing to catalyze private capital
and there's a couple of different ways
and ideas that we could deploy in the
near term
the first is incentivizing private
capital
we need to reduce the hurdles that
frequently restrict the ability to bring
private Capital to the table so that's
aligning things like the global
interpretation of Basel Capital rules
and Country regulations around the world
it's a tad complex today
by aligning the global interpretation of
these rules will help us lower Capital
treatment requirements
um so that those associated with MDB
risk mitigation will enable more private
capital in non-investment grade assets
which is the most critical piece here to
flow in so what is currently a trickle
can become a sustainable material flow
the second is also just about sharing
expertise led by the World Bank let's
bring together technical experts from
both sides so from the development Banks
and the financial institutions so we can
create more modern Financial structures
financial institutions such as City have
Capital markets and structuring
expertise that mdbs don't have whilst
the mdbs have the geopolitical knowledge
and project proficiency including vast
amounts of performance decade
performance data over decades that could
really reduce down risk and pricing
therefore of these projects that the
Capital Market side that we lack so
bringing this together would be very
valuable and it would be remiss of me if
I didn't ask for actions to not only
mobilize the capital but to accelerate
getting projects actually online so
permitting and the mundane but important
activities such as streamlining
documentation and contracts and
standardizing them would make an
enormous difference
so it's not that hard I am confident
that if we have stronger collaboration
we can create enduring and sustainable
flows of capital from the private sector
that would raise the economic futures of
developing countries around the world
thank you
is
thank you very much prime minister Your
Excellence is it's a pleasure to be here
to represent the digital technology
industry and thank you president
funalayan for the invitation I would
like to share Nokia's perspective on how
to make initiatives like pgii and global
gateway as impactful impactful as
possible
digitalization and connectivity improve
safety productivity efficiency and
sustainability that's a fact they are
particularly effective in physical
Industries such as Agriculture and
Manufacturing making them highly
relevant in all developing economies
transcontinental connectivity with
subsea cables such as Medusa in the
Mediterranean Sea or the plant far north
fiber linking Japan North America
northern Europe binds us together even
more strongly
so encouraging digitalization and
connectivity in partnership with trusted
reliable actors should be one of the
pgii's most important objectives we
should be asking ourselves when any
developing economy wants to invest in
digital infrastructure or commit to
digitalizing its economy how can we make
sure that G7 Nations and their trusted
vendors are the partners of choice a big
part of the answer is financing G7
economies have done tremendous work in
getting initiatives like pgii and global
gateway off the ground
they are the best channel to make
financing competitive attractive and
joined up and they can enable impact on
a huge scale across sectors and
continents but we can still make the
financial side of these initiatives even
more attractive speaking for business we
would like development Banks and Export
Credit Agencies from G7 Nations to
jointly develop attractive financing
tools and offers to support trusted and
sustainable infrastructure so these
tools and offers can become even more
effective I'm proud that Nokia is a
partner for trusted digitalization
we are working closely with the European
commission to develop global gateway
digital flagships to benefit countries
Industries and communities please
consider these projects alongside other
project digitalization opportunities
with the urgency they deserve thank you
um
thank you Mr Prime Minister I thank the
G7 for inviting us to be part of this
session Gip we are one of the largest
managers of infrastructure assets around
the world we have 100 billion of assets
that we invest in companies in
energy transport water and waste and
digital sectors
I should say we have substantial
investment in every single one of the G7
countries and I did one prime minister
Trudeau that Canada is the exception but
we're working hard to rectify that
we agree that mobilizing private
capitals is critical to addressing the
urgent need for emerging market
infrastructure investment
to date together with our portfolio
companies we have invested over 15
billion dollars of equity to provide
critical infrastructure services in over
20 Emerging Market countries
in Asia our Vena Energy company is
helping to tackle climate and energy
security issues by building and
operating three gigawatts of solar and
wind farms in India Indonesia the
Philippines and Thailand
Outlets Renewable Energy company is
doing the same thing in Latin America
with over four gigawatts of operating
and under construction solar plants in
Brazil Uruguay Chile and Colombia
over the next 10 years we are Gip aim to
invest some 20 billion dollars in
businesses that will provide essential
infrastructure in Emerging Market
countries
turn into how the G7 and pgii can
turbine charge the flow of private
capital in the emerge Market
infrastructure we have three suggestions
one is to provide approval of capital to
support an instrument which can be
modeled after the war bank's partial
risk guarantee program that helps the
lower the perceived risk of these
Investments through for a fee providing
a g-lev G7 level backstop for some
Emerging Market country obligations and
undertakings however unlike the World
Bank apologies David the program must be
user-friendly non-bureaucratic quick
acting Nimble and flexible
this will materially lower the cost of
providing Emerging Market infrastructure
Investments
a second suggestion is to explore ways
in which pgii can provide support for
the development of critical Financial
products in Emerging Market countries
things like longer tenor local currency
financing and long-dated currency and
interest rate Hedges that will again
help lower the cost and perceived risk
of Emerging Market country Investments
a third and final suggestion is to
provide a forum for facilitating the
regular flow of information about
investment opportunities in Emerging
Market countries and for educating
private sector investors about the tools
and instruments that are available from
pgii to support these Investments we at
Gip stand ready to support the G7 and
PGI in this important undertaking thank
you very much
foreign
thank you thank you very much prime
minister uh and thank you for hosting us
here and also for leading the quality
infrastructure efforts for nearly a
decade
um infrastructure development needs vast
resources I think the ambition should be
large to create a dynamic investable
asset class for infrastructure in
developing countries that provides
Geographic and sectoral diversification
climate infrastructure can clearly be an
important portion of this asset class as
should be toll roads electricity
transmission assets electricity
distribution and many types of water
related assets all of these are
currently underfunded but would be
attractive to investors if properly
packaged there are three main steps to
achieve this standards verification of
results and standardization of contracts
and techniques this can make thousands
of individual assets available to
investors an important early step is to
converge on a set of measurement
standards there are many examples
underway now at the 2019 G20 Osaka
Summit the World Bank was a key part of
creating the quality infrastructure
investment partnership uh effort this
will help mainstream qii principles in
more than 22 billion dollars of World
Bank projects several different
standards and taxonomies are under
discussion for sustainability disclosure
and climate Finance the asean taxonomy
was offered as a model in nigata last
week
the issb and the US SEC have proposed
sustainability reporting standards the
World Bank group supports harmonization
of Standards to reduce cost and enhance
transparency and we have published and
been one of the first to publish
comprehensive Paris alignment guidelines
for our instruments and sectors the
second step is creating financing
instruments with verifiable results that
make projects attractive and salable to
donors and investors investors want to
invest but they need to avoid green
washing at first this can be done one
Innovation at a time and we've done that
with City uh as with the water
purification Bond and in South Africa
with the black rhino Bond these are
useful uh starting points to move to
bigger projects focused on greenhouse
gas emission reduction we've launched a
multi-donor trust fund called scale that
would bring concessional resources and
the third necessary step is
standardization of contracts this will
allow risk diversification and can
create a robust climate infrastructure
asset class we heard from two of the
investors the importance of having a
forum and having expertise that shares
knowledge on this so with that let me
conclude on an important related issue
to become investable countries need to
do more to facilitate private Capital we
are actively strengthening our support
to enable private capital and strengthen
private sectors this involves a more
holistic World Bank group effort for
example countries have been accustomed
to holding their best assets in
government Enterprises the World Bank
IFC and Miga can combine their efforts
to help make these assets more
sustainable and marketable ideally this
is part of a country's overall effort to
facilitate private Capital inflows
including for climate I want to thank
Japan and all of you for the engagement
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Java
is Indonesia
activities
infrastructure
energy
[Music]
renewable energy
showcase transformation
technology
infrastructure
women
investor
[Music]
Indonesia
infestation concrete and innovative
foreign
[Music]
minister
because
foreign
[Music]
an Afric
a
convey
[Music]
because
entrepreneurial
[Music]
according foreign
foreign
relations
thank you prime minister let me
reinforce also the message by two
previous leaders and give you a specific
perspective on infrastructure investment
there are a number of things that
conspire
to make infrastructure investment in the
Pacific Islands difficult one is the
small population of many of our
countries the micro economies which make
the return on investment very difficult
difficult to recoup
the distance in my country of the Cook
Islands a distance from the main island
to the northernmost island is the same
distance as London to Rome this is just
one of the countries
and also the diseconomies of scale
it means that
capital investment in infrastructure on
a per capita basis is disproportionately
high for Pacific island countries
too often we see the trade-off between
infrastructure development and fiscal
space because of the debt burden that
often accompanies infrastructure
investment
when we do invest what this does on our
balance sheet is the depreciation value
adds again to our balance sheet which
gives us a disproportionate or distorts
our balance sheets for us
the cost of not doing this
infrastructure investment such as
sealing a runway on one of our Islands
it doesn't matter whether you're sealing
it for a thousand people or a hundred
thousand people the cost is still the
same
but if you don't do that then what you
see is the population on these remote
Islands
becoming part of the migrant labor force
that moves to other countries to find
work
and in our country like the other two
countries you're not just looking at one
airstrip that you have the seal in my
country we have to look at 10 airstrips
that we have to seal so the cost is
replicated it's magnified and that's
just for connectivity we're also talking
about digital connectivity with either
satellite or cable we're looking at
replicating power generation on each of
these small island communities
it's important then
for the G7 and partners to look at
tailoring the type of support that you
can provide for small microeconomies in
order for them to be able to participate
in the main synthes economic growth in
order for these small communities to
earn a living
so they don't have to leave the country
thank you prime minister
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much well much has been
said so I don't need to uh say too much
other than I agree entirely which is
what everything that has been said so
far I want to thank the U.S uh Japan and
the EU for convening this I want to
thank the leaders of emerging economies
the key private sector players along
with my other G7 colleagues investing to
close the infrastructure Gap will grow
the economy create good jobs for the
middle class and help reduce poverty all
around the world at the G20 Summit last
November Canada announced 750 million
dollar recapitalization of our
development Finance institution thindev
Canada to help support infrastructure
investment in the indo-pacific and
Beyond today I'm announcing that Canada
will contribute an additional 335
million dollars for Quality sustainable
infrastructure working with findev
Canada the merova gigaton fund the
maramantha energy investment srl and the
European bank for reconstruction and
development
[Music]
foreign
impact
hey issues
thank you
so we launched last year this initiative
in Elmo and uh
it works really well since then and
thank you from you for your leadership
and and active activity to make this
something that is continuously making
progress it is very important that we
meet together today to continue with all
the activities it's about mobilizing
public but also and mostly private
capital for direct investment into the
countries and it is necessary that we do
it within this framework because it
creates the environment the ecosystem
where such Investments can take place
and this is why I really think we should
put our different initiatives together
so there is also this G20 compact with
Africa which is important to convince
um countries that there is a chat an
environment necessary for this way of
investment and if we are continuously
working into this direction I think this
will be very very good thank you
foreign
[Music]
is a concrete intelligent a serious way
of cooperating with low and
middle-income countries with a known
predatory approach uh investment
infrastructures the guarantee a higher
multiplier than those in current
expenditures and they Foster a concrete
development for the future of these
nations and that is why Italy has
guaranteed its support through the EU
global gateway
focusing moreover on Africa with two
projects in connectivity areas that form
part of our mate plan for Africa and the
first area is energy
in this regard the helmet submarine
cable which connects the electricity
product production of Italy and Tunisia
is a significant project and it is part
of the Italian strategy to invest in
energy production
in Africa in the second area is data in
this context I wish to recall at least
two project the blue Ramen which
connects the indo-pacific with Europe
and North Africa creating an important
connection system between three
continents and they already recalled
Medusa optical fiber cable which
significantly enhances internet
connectivity for North African
University and supports the training of
African in a concrete way we strongly
believe in this approach and this issue
will be one of the priorities of the
Italian presidency of G7 in 2024
foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]